mona où êtes-vous précisément et comment
se déroule cette manifestation
parisienne alors une semaine avant
l'appel national du 14 mai les gilets
jaunes ont décidé de se mobiliser ils
sont quelques centaines y ciel s'être
rassemblés dans une ambiance plutôt
calme et dans une ambiance ap hm c'est
jovial on entend souvent elles des
slogans anti gouvernement et vous le
voyez sur ces images ici derrière ils
sont plusieurs centaines à être toujours
mobilisés être toujours motivé il a une
importance policière assez conséquente
il ya presque autant de policiers que de
manifestants regarder sur les images sur
ces images la présence policière
ici qui est juste en tête du cortège ici
juste devant et qui encadre
vraisemblablement tout le cortège des
gilets jaunes
ici je vous propose notamment d'écouter
l'organisatrice de cette mobilisation de
cet acte 69 des gilet jaune inda bigot
alors moi ce que j'ai pu constater dans
leurs discours au sein de l'hémicycle
quand j'écoute moi monsieur edouard
philippe
lorsqu'il est en train de
de parler de certaines mesures
concernant le système social et ses
valets paient les retraites et personnes
handicapées
je me dis oui ils nous écoutent même
s'ils ne nous reçoivent pas mais ils ne
font que balancer de la poudre de
perlimpinpin en fait parce que dans les
faits il n'y a aucune mesure puisque il
n'écoute pas les mesures émanant du
peuple
jusqu'à présent ça fait six mois qu'on
est dehors on n'a pas cessé de demander
des pourparlers avec une délégation du
club pour le club ça n'est pas entendue
ça n'est pas reçue ils nous font croire
qu'ils nous écoutons qu'ils entendent la
rue mais dans les faits il n'y a rien
contre à quoi puisqu'ils continuent
leurs quatre pieds de détruire
complètement nos institutions et
concernant cette mobilisation même s'ils
ne sont que quelques centaines ils
disent que la réforme des retraites et
le recours du gouvernement 49,3
mobilisées lé troupes en tout cas il
reste motivé je vous propose d'écouter
les gilet jaune à etienne a pu parler et
on est actuellement 9 millions pauvres
il faudrait que 20 à 25 millions de
pauvres pour que y ait beaucoup de gens
beaucoup plus de gens concernés et qui
viennent et qui ceux qui sortent et que
là peut-être qui aura une vraie
révolution mais tant qu'on n'a pas 25 ou
30 millions de vrais gens pauvres en
france sa vie votre à un petit peu comme
ça comme ça se passe en ce moment il ya
peut-être des week-ends aussi un peu
plus fort parce qu'il ya des appels
nationaux à gauche à droite mais sinon
ça persiste oui mais pour que ça prenne
de l'ampleur comme je vous dis il faut
qu'ils paient plus de gens qui aient
faim je suis là pour mes enfants mes
petits enfants tous les jeunes et disons
c'est pour leur retraite et beaucoup de
choses du mieux vivre parce que
on va dans le fond que de plus en plus
et ils ont ils n'ont pas d'avenir pour
moi ils n'ont pas d'avenir
je pense qu'on n'a jamais été écouté par
le gouvernement il fait semblant il est
des trucs qui nous ment et ensuite on
est censé eux sensé dire que croire
qu'il skie dit au début du salon de
l'agriculture il dit qui passent pas au
49 3 le samedi il annonce je sais pas si
on peut dire qu'ils disent la vérité
non on n'est pas écoutés il nous manque
vous l'avez entendu de chez les jeunes
qui restent mobilisés vous n'entendez
d'ailleurs derrière moi une ambiance
assez assez jovial le tout en musique
avec des instruments rien en plus qu'à
se partagent vous l'avez dit inquiet
partie à 13 heures devant la gare de
l'est pourrait se terminer dans l'après
midi
ap l'accès partout de chanter
mohamud et l'or merci pour ces
précisions